In this video, we'll look at utilizing
the packaged build of the project
to understand better how OSC functions.
When you look at the extracted folder
that came with this project,
you'll look in the packaged folder and find that
there's an executable file as well as two batch files.
Now to start, if you just want to test
sending what we call one-way communication,
where the sender is sending
data and being received by another computer,
all you need to do is open up the sender batch file
and change the receiver IP address
to the local IPv4 address
of the computer you're on right now.
Using the IP config, as June demonstrated earlier,
you'll then find that with two instances open
on the same computer or two computers
on the same local network,
you'll find that whoever has the sender batch file opened
will be able to affect the scene,
changing both the scale of the cubes,
whether they're on and off or the colors of them.
If you would like to use the packaged builds
and test two-way functionality,
if you're on the same subnet
on the same local area network,
you'll just need to make sure that both the sender IP
and receiver IP is set up.
And again, on a local subnet,
you can just use the IPv4 addresses
that show up when you type in IP config on each computer.
However, if you want to make sure
that this will work over the internet,
then you will actually need to utilize using something
like what's my IP address in Google
to find out what the WAN is for your actual IP.
And then that data would be put into here
alongside making sure that your port forwarding
has already been completed to open up communication
between those two computers across different networks.
Please also ensure that the final launch parameter
dash osc2a is set to equal true.
Otherwise it will still be set up
to only send data in one direction.
So now on the screen,
we're seeing that the right-hand side
is my local computer in my apartment.
And on the left side,
we're running this app on a office computer.
So now we can see that when the office computer
is controlling the pink bar,
we see a lot of the print strings.
It's just saying that I received a message.
The address is float slash Z and the value.
And if I do it, it's also printing on the other side.
So that's how we can make sure.
Well, and also the pink bar moves with the location.
So that's how we can confirm we're receiving the messages.
And now if I change the color of the cubes,
it will also change on the other side.
And as you can see,
all these are not happening inside a multiplayer session.
So we are just like,
we are only controlling the cubes,
but not replicating actors or,
or sorry, but not replicating the character movements.
So we can be very selective about what are the things
we want to communicate and what are not.
We have the Boolean messages here,
integer messages here.
Oh, it's off.
And a float message from here.
And because this is set up for two way communication
right now, I also have the same capabilities
as June does.
So I am also able to do things like change color
or turn the cubes off and on.